[Music]
plane ride
bird
does this mean
okay
i think you're referring to the white
knuckle charter company
yeah yeah that's the one
so basically what happened is my parents
they launched the safari business
and
it slowly started to become successful
but they started to run into a problem
as my sister and i were getting older
because school started to become an
issue so there was obviously no nowhere
to take us to school living out here
so they decided that what they would do
is they would learn to fly
and then they would ferry us in to the
nearest town and we would be we would
sort of attend early preschool over
whatever it's called like
monday through wednesday and then
wednesday we would fly back
to the reserve and we would be here
through the weekend and we were
basically getting three days of
schooling that seemed like enough to
them at the time
so they took up flying
and my memories of it are that when we
when they would pick us up on a
wednesday afternoon
to be honest they weren't great pilots
so they were they were in a bit of a
state you know the first 50 hours of
being a pilot there's a lot of stress
about getting it in the air and then
safely getting it back on the ground so
they would arrive and they would say to
us we're in flying mode right now and
flying mode meant we could not ask any
questions we had to shut up kids you
kids shut up we're in flying mode
and then they had this other sort of
drill that they worked out with each
other which was called pilot in command
and
you know when they were up front there
in the cockpit the one would say i am
now pilot in command and if you hand it
over control you would say handing over
control and the other would say i am now
piloting command pilot in command
handing over to pilot in command i am
now pilot in command and they had this
whole drill right
the first crash that we were involved in
we came in to land and we had a plane it
was a little cessna that had a quirk and
let me tell you when it comes to
aviation you don't want planes with
quirks you can have a quirky like pickup
track but you cannot have a quirky
aircraft the quirk was that when you
pulled the power
not all power cut off it kept a little
bleed of power on so my mother was
flying the plane she came in to land on
the little 800 meter you know dirt strip
she cut the power the plane sort of
landed but it just kept on a little too
much power and we kept going and she
started to say to my father and my
sister and i are watching from the back
in flying mode uh i can't get the power
off i can't get the power off i can't
get the speed off and he says he's
saying to her you are pilot in command
you are pilot in command and she's going
i know but i can't get the speed off and
eventually she kicks the rudder and the
plane veers off the runway and we hit a
marilla tree and we stop
that that's our first crash
and it's one of those it's one of those
ones tim that if you bring it up today
like at dinner he will say we'll say
well you know i couldn't get the speed
off and he'll say my father will say
well you were pilot in command and
immediately a fight will develop at
dinner i know i was patted in come on
but before we hit the tree do you think
you could have pulled the power you
could have so like it's a little tension
around it anyway
the worst one was
we were flying a short hop and by this
stage
my parents had launched you know a
bigger safari company
and they had decided that when they flew
they should actually have a commercial
pilot with them
and so the setup was
it's a commercial pilot in the left-hand
seat it's my father in the right-hand
seat and then there's
club seating four seats in the back so
but you sit facing each other like you
would on a train you know like looking
at each other
so we're flying along and i see my
mother and her friend are sitting
opposite me
and they're looking towards the cockpit
i'm looking back at them
and suddenly we just hear this
outrageous like sound
and wind fills the cockpit and it's just
this incredible rushing sound
amazing sound
looking at my mother and her friend next
to her
it looks like pulp fiction there is just
blood and guts all over them it looks
like someone took a bird put it in a
blender and made like a bird smoothie
and then threw it over them they've got
a wing on their head they've got a foot
on their shoulder they are covered in
blood and guts and so i turn and i look
back at the cockpit the front window of
the plane is gone
the pilot
is conked out he's passed out in his
seat and my father is like orientating
himself in the madness
and
right at that moment as he sort of as my
father got his bearings i saw him grab
the controls and then he looked back at
me and said
i am pilot in command and
and so now
now we we realize we've got a situation
what had happened is we had hit
a stalk
direct bird strike
and the bird had come in the window
and in fact
the beak of the bird had gone into had
hit the pilot the bird had hit the pilot
the beak had gone into the skin
um between the pilot's skull and the
skin so he had a beak sticking out of
his face and a bit of stalk neck
sticking out of his face and he's
totally passed out meantime my father
has taken control of the plane the woman
on the back seat screaming next to my
mom is going we're all gonna die we're
all gonna die and that's when my mother
gave her the patented mother slap
slapped her twice and said we are not
gonna die
and then out of nowhere my mother
reaches into her sort of handbag and
pulls out a flight call sheet and she
starts screaming
standard emergency practices to my
father
call sos bass request emergency landing
and he's ticking off things
now at this point the pilot starts to
wake up
and he wakes up and he's slowly gaining
his bearings
and
as he looks around he has this strange
kind of
dot in his vision and as he's looking
around the dot follows him
and he eventually puts his hand up and
what it is it's the stalk's neck
sticking out of his face that everywhere
he looks it's in his line of sight
because it's connected to his face
and it was at that moment that he
grabbed the neck and the beak of the
stalk and he pulled it out of his face
and looked at it and then passed out
again
and i don't know if you've ever seen a
head wound but head wounds bleed nicely
and so he's bleeding quite intensely
it's pandemonium back it there but my
folks have got the controls they call
the airport my father starts the descent
and eventually the pilot wakes up and he
comes too and he's actually he's all
right and he takes over control of the
plane again and we do an emergency
landing
and the funny thing about it was
we were flying from the reserve to go
and catch a commercial flight so we
landed at a commercial airport and we
got out covered in stork stalk wing and
stock foot and stork guts and we walked
into the terminal building and i said to
my mother well what do we do now she
said just board the flight and look
forward so we got onto the plane looking
like we had been in the texas chainsaw
massacre and just sat down next to
regular folks traveling
covered in guts and blood and just sat
there and looked forward and flew to our
next destination like nothing had
happened
but it was a you know we grew up in a
real wild way we grew up in a pioneering
way and my parents were
irrepressible i think is the word
but you kind of have to be to run a
safari business where things
you know running a safari business
you're out in nature and things are
happening
and and unexpected things are happening
almost continuously so that was kind of
uh
my wild youth in some ways you know it
was very very orientated towards that
kind of south african wildness and and
also i think that we were we've changed
a lot over the years but
and we've been in our own healing
journeys and our own healing journeys
have changed us as a family for sure
but for many years there we were just
kind of packing on uh
you know i guess we were frozen by some
trauma ourselves and we were just living
as wildly through it as we could
you